this may be the most
important speech i've ever made
president trump tonight releasing this
bizarre
46-minute long speech but i went from
leading by a lot to losing by a little
filled with more baseless accusations of
election fraud
we have in all swing states major
infractions
or outright fraud if we are right about
the fraud
joe biden can't be president but court
after court has ruled the president
is wrong about the fraud and his
campaign lacks credible evidence
the president's own attorney general
bill barr says the department of justice
has found no widespread fraud that would
change the election result
today the white house would not say if
president trump still has confidence in
barr
if he has any personnel announcements
he'll be the first to know it and the
white house is also dodging questions
about reports
that president trump is considering
preemptive pardons
for three of his adult children and his
son-in-law jared kushner
egged on by his fox news supporters why
wouldn't he just pardon himself and his
family
on the way out the door none of his
children has been charged with any crime
ivanka trump was deposed yesterday as
part of an investigation into the misuse
of inauguration funds
donald trump jr was investigated by
special counsel robert mueller for
contacts with russians during the 2016
campaign
and kushner provided false information
while applying for his security
clearance
but granting preemptive pardons is very
rare
but legally there's no problem with
granting a preempted pardon
the famous nixon pardon was a preemptive
pardon nixon had not been formally
charged
with any crimes yet and while president
trump continues to allege the election
was stolen
everyone is saying wow the evidence is
overwhelming at a white house christmas
party last night
he teased a re-election run in 2024
the president is not conceding and
administration officials tell cbs news
they do not expect president trump to
attend joe biden's inauguration
that would make mr trump the first
sitting u.s president to snub his
successor
since andrew johnson back in 1869
ben tracy cbs news the white house